we wanted to hear how people living
along the southern border view the
crackdown on illegal immigration we
spoke with one man who told us his name
was Frank here in McAllen he told us
that he left Mexico when he was seven he
came here on a visa and became a US
citizen at 18
Frank is now 49 has children and is in
the construction business you know I
don't mean to sound insensitive but we
can't just open up the borders a lot of
times we lose our jobs because a lot of
these people come in and they're willing
to do a job for a portion of the pain
and so we're deaf town this is bigger
though than opening up the borders this
is about children being separated from
their parents what do you say about that
I don't agree with that you don't agree
with that bud but my opinion is we can't
just open up a course what's the
solution
as an immigrant yourself Oh work with
the governments were there with their
countries whether fromming trying to get
them to some jobs out there but you came
here yes seeking a better life
yes doesn't that seem like a
contradiction is an immigrant yourself
yes it does another year I can see the
point of you other people that live here
and most of the people coming here are
not they are law-abiding citizens agree
with that yes most of them are yeah when
you hear those strong opinions from both
sides it really hits home that this
immigration debate is not easy to
resolve we've been saying all along it
is very complicated